all right let's go to our next caller
why don't we talk to someone from oh I
don't know maybe the 203 area code
caller from 203 tell us your name where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today
um hi there um my name is Monica
Connecticut area code but I'm calling
from Vermont
okay great what's on your mind well I
had just been catching up on some of
your different segments and I was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
in regards to the Russian hacking and
whether this will maybe finally be what
sort of causes us as a whole to look at
the electoral college and how vulnerable
it is you know to something that would
tip the scales like this you know I know
that we don't know precisely whether any
votes were fabricated or altered but I
think it's really something to look at
because you know it's much harder to
fabricate you know 3.1 million votes in
a popular election or alter in some
fashion than maybe an electoral college
when you really only have to tip a few
small scales in a few small states um
right just wondering your thoughts on
that
yes spot-on Monica so if you do want to
consider how vulnerable an electoral
system is to vote flipping any system
where the ultimate results could hinge
on a smaller number of votes is more
vulnerable so if we imagine the national
popular vote system where one candidate
in 2016 for example had nearly three
million more votes than the other
candidate Hillary Clinton versus Donald
Trump you would need to reverse nearly
three million votes through hacking in
order to change the outcome of the
election with the electoral college the
reversal of just 77,000 votes across
three states could have reversed the
ultimate result so from a mathematical
standpoint there's no denying whatsoever
that the electoral college system is
more vulnerable to hacking but I also
want to get to sort of the first part of
your question Monica which is there is
way more than just
lating votes that is relevant from the
Russia investigation and I want to make
that clear not because it's unclear to
you necessarily although I guess I don't
know but there are lots of people who
email using David the entire Russia
story doesn't matter because there's no
evidence that they actually flipped
votes and thus influence the election in
that way and my response to all of those
people is this Russia story goes well
beyond hacking machines
to flip votes we are talking here about
meddling at the state level we are
talking about potential collusion and
coordination with the Trump
administration and moreover as we talked
about it's often not the crime or the
transgression it's the attempt to cover
up or obstruct the investigation it's
now moved well beyond just the initial
facts of it and into whether or not
Donald Trump and his associates have
attempted to or have obstructed the
investigations into this so you're
absolutely right Monica ours our
electoral system is much more vulnerable
to having results flipped as a result of
hacking by its very nature but at the
same time there's way more than that
when it comes to the Russia story to be
talking about and I hope you know that
yes yes thank you yeah all right very
good not a thank you you think all
really appreciate it
I think did we lose Monica I think so
I've been stream that okay very good
questions today we will take a break and
be back with more after this on the
Friday show